and then there is a clip of this I don't
know what said it might leave a scarcely
died
mrs. giant that we did a video on where
he was arguing with the journalist in
the car with his like blue eyes but
that's because he got eyes time he got
his little Hong look at this con artist
[Music]
about his dumb power I'll never be back
thank you look at those grown men cause
it down the far left don't get corona
dude no window a strong it doesn't have
to be dude squad up squad up no 40-mile
now I don't have to you're not for a
mile now just hot look at this guy hey
we know what heart is in Texas this
thing is gonna hit in New Orleans well
I'm telling you it gets hot down there
I'm in jail just be making [ __ ] up on
the fly it's creative though it's right
there on a coat he gets lucky and that's
what it takes to kill this thing
it hates heat it hates humidity it hates
water it just dies
burn burn over the background
environment remember anything says they
repeat win the win it's even better he'd
be amazing on WWE is it's even better if
there's no wind at all because I want to
tell you yeah you a California boy you
don't know much about this but son you
ain't never seen hard until it gets hot
in Texas I love this guy yes muggy down
hit his hairpiece and in New Orleans and
it gets I don't know what that guy's
thinking
oh it starts on I can't even go outside
that's good stay in the house they turn
on the air-conditioner and watch that
diamond I watch it die right in front of
it just get some rain yeah look at his
eyes he's got ball dude you can't be 80
and get your eyes down like they're
worth more full of [ __ ] than that guy
well he's a bad guy obviously look dude
he's the scariest guy he's such a creepy
that wears what that's what second wear
is named Kenneth Copeland boys ballin
though oh yeah hit me miss boys God you
think they'd go over [ __ ] like they have
a a brainstorming session before this or
does he just gotta go where they just
goes he's got his thing goes man he's
been doing so many years you improvise
your preacher blow the way I get to
spare it in me
hey Bri how about the other four grow in
of God how about the other four grow
mango you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah well they
getting paid to our thing and that's
their boss it's entertainment and that's
their boss and what else are they gonna
do what else are they gonna do not much
because they've got their own following
probably they're also like they also got
it they got franchise that he franchises
his ministry right Todd so that's the
that's the Copeland ministries mm-hmm
look at that suit he's got some money
flies privately number of private jets a
bunch of sad angels I gotta get to
models I have to get to my people I have
to get to my flock uh yeah I gotta get
to my flock and the wind of God there's
boys oh yeah because God knows there's
some other scary ones on there too is he
got his eyes done look at that's crazy
that is frightening yeah he had his
brows lifted I think he's also bit me he
might be Satan as well see how old he is
it has to be 80 something right there is
something you only 3 years old when you
get to be a mystery you don't give a
[ __ ] anymore do you I'm 83
what you do but you do look go with her
order you never felt the heat like a
Texas heat he's one of his books is that
you at California boy you California boy
plus 45 more studious 45 bucks pursued
his present pursuit healing scripture
Wow stare dude I'm tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]